rutte à 29 ans elle travaille dans le
secteur du conseil inscrits sur la
plateforme ensemble depuis six mois elle
n'a jamais autant rendu service à ses
voisins que pendant le confinement
aujourd'hui chez elle s'est occupée de
faire quelques courses pour son voisin
du rez-de-chaussée coincés à la maison
avec ses enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai voulu la rendre service pendants
confinement donc je me suis mis sur
l'application peut leur demander si vous
avez besoin de quelque chose je le
rappelais m application c'était bien
drôle et est en fait blanc fil de l'eau
et nîmes ont posé des questions pour
savoir si je pouvais en même temps au
début début elle est à la poste pour eux
ou des choses comme ça et au fil du
temps c'était vraiment faire des courses
pour eux pendant que j'ai les miennes
surtout on se connaît mieux en un an
dans ce salut tous je me fais lettre à
l'autre alors qu'avant de visas vis par
un problème donc maintenant oui ça crée
beaucoup de bien ça crée des liens et
puis surtout ça permet de connaître ses
voisins les connaît jamais et puis hélas
ils ont tellement mais parfois c'est
nous qui avons tant de moi aussi parfois
j'ai fait mes voisins pour dépanner
pas forcément pour aller faire des
courses mais pour pourfendre petites
choses qu'on a promis des motards
meubles voilà des petites choses qui me
manque d'ingrédients rang des choses
comme ça demandez à d'autres de faire
ses courses en service de grande valeur
particulièrement aujourd'hui terrifié
par l'idée d'être contaminés ou de
transmettre le virus à son mari jacques
lainet 80 ans n'a plus mis un pied
dehors depuis un mois et ne reçoit
aucune visite non plus lui de mon mari
en état de fait est fait et son problème
on m'a conseillé de ne pas être en
contact avec d'autres personnes
surtout pour ne rien lui transmettre ça
me réchauffe énormément le coeur de sa
voix que j'ai quelqu'un qui parlait ac
l'expliqué que je veux c'est très
important
ouf l'amabilité et la compréhension de
personnes qui vont envers lui donnant à
issy les moulineaux en passant par pau
une centaine de collectivités ont adopté
ce réseau social local
un bénévolat à la carte ponctuelles et
solidaire c'est la recette du succès de
cette plateforme numérique des habitants
se mobilisent et complètement pour un
peu qu'ils ne soient pas estampillé
bénévoles donc c'est ça le point c'est
que heureusement que le bénévolat le
bénévolat exit s'est fait de plus en
plus rare et très compliqué on est tous
occupés prix
là le principe est énorme ce que tout le
monde peut aider ce que je peux venir là
simplement pour ce qui m'intéresse à la
fin je peux aider parce que ça se passe
à côté de chez moi quand je peux et si
je veux depuis la mise en place du
confinement 85 communes et une trentaine
de départements se sont montrés
intéressés pour déployer ce nouvel outil
sur leur territoire